Hey everyone, welcome back to Mentor and yet another rerun show from my earlier episodes
that I did on my earlier YouTube channel.
This one is about first of the programs, paid to fly programs and buying your own type
rating.
I hope you enjoy it.
There wouldn't be new content coming out maybe early next week or so.
But up until then you'll have to make do with all my earlier shows.
So please sit back, relax and enjoy it, thank you.
So I have been receiving a couple of questions during this week and before that as well about
first officer programs or paid to fly programs and also to pay for type ratings if that's
a good idea or not.
And before I start I just want to say that I don't have much experience at all when it
comes to paid to fly programs or first of the programs.
I do have experience of paying for my own type rating however.
So first of the programs, well what they are is essentially a airline or several airlines
that are offering low hours just out of school flying cadets the possibility to come in
and work for that airline for a limited amount of time, normally up to 100 or 500 or even
up to a thousand hours.